durante años Fue una fuente de
inspiración para los grandes estudios de
Hollywood pero la Inteligencia
artificial ha dejado de ser una ficción
en plena huelga de guionistas ahora
aparece como una amenaza en las
pancartas de los manifestantes
sabemos lo que nos espera nosotros
imaginamos Terminator entonces sabemos
lo que va a llegar tarde o temprano es
uno de los temas centrales de las
negociaciones y realmente me asusta
porque si los ordenadores empiezan a
escribir una primera versión de un guión
en vez de un humano eso eliminará
algunos trabajos
Temo que en el futuro le delegan cada
vez más tareas a la Inteligencia
artificial y eso producirá películas
estandarizadas que nadie va a querer ver
será el equivalente de la comida rápida
en la televisión y me da miedo que algún
Villano quiera perfeccionar esa
tecnología y deshacerse de una vez por
todas de los guionistas
es un escenario de ciencia ficción o se
avecina una gran transformación en
Hollywood como ocurrió hace un siglo con
la llegada del cine sonoro
este director quiso averiguarlo decidió
generar el primer guión escrito de
principio a fin por la Inteligencia
artificial
estoy escribiendo quisiera ayuda para
escribir un guión de largometraje por
favor sugiéreme 10 ideas
tras unos 10 minutos y después de unos
cuantos intercambios a través de la
plataforma
de una película de ciencia ficción 30
años estadounidense de origen asiático
apresurado entra en la habitación con
una taza de café Nick dice hola doctor
Te traje café será una larga noche
Este es un ejemplo típico si el director
de un estudio leyera este guión para
decidirse hacer o no una película lo
tiraría la basura de inmediato porque
está plagado de clichés de lugares
comunes
en este punto el resultado es
impresionante en la forma pero está
lejos de ser original la razón es que la
Inteligencia artificial se nutre de
miles de guiones que ya se han escrito
lo mismo ocurre para la generación de
imágenes hace unas semanas se viralizó
este tráiler falso que recrea el estilo
de un director icónico
aquí se comprueba que la Inteligencia
artificial sabe tomar el universo de
West Anderson y el de Star Wars y
combinarlos pero lo que todavía no la he
visto hacer y no estoy seguro de que
logre algún día es crear algo realmente
nuevo que además conmueva a los seres
humanos pero algo es seguro en Hollywood
la Industria Del entretenimiento está
cada vez más interesada hoy
representantes de la tecnología y del
mundo del cine se reúnen en un seminario
sobre Inteligencia artificial en la
agenda del día presentación de
herramientas revolucionarias para cada
etapa del proceso desde el rodaje hasta
la postproducción como este programa que
permite reemplazar casi al instante a un
actor por un personaje animado sin ayuda
de diseñadores gráficos es muy útil para
este tipo de trabajo que toma semanas a
ser solo para llegar al mismo resultado
dejemos que la Inteligencia artificial
nos ayude a obtener resultados más
rápidos eso permitirá que se pueda decir
algo que suele pasar a eso no sirve hay
que volverlo a hacer pero ahora se puede
rehacer y tardar dos semanas menos para
los estudios la Inteligencia artificial
promete sobre todo un gran aumento de la
productividad creo que cuando salgamos
de esta época de crisis dentro de seis
meses estas herramientas estarán más
aceptadas en particular entre los
estudios porque han visto el resultado
quieren esta tecnología y la tendrán la
situación se está extendiendo por el
mundo de la creación artística
en escena el DJ David Guetta recreó La
Voz del rapero Eminem
sin que este nunca hubiera cantado esa
canción
[Música]
esta banda de pop escribió en 2019 un
álbum entero usando Inteligencia
artificial en esa época la tecnología
todavía estaba en desarrollo lo que
hicimos fue tomar una melodía de nuestro
repertorio el formato midi es decir los
datos digitales que corresponden a esa
melodía tomamos una segunda melodía las
juntamos en el sistema y el programa
exploró todo el espacio que existía
entre esas dos melodías pareció que ahí
había algo interesante pensamos que esto
podría ser una línea de base y como solo
son notas que salen de un programa no se
suele considerar que podría ser difícil
lo extraño tocarlo en un bajo es una
especie de colaboración una colaboración
que sacó a la banda de su zona de
Confort pero no necesariamente los
convenció de seguir por ese camino a
largo plazo para mí y para la mayoría de
los músicos que conozco esta tecnología
se ha vuelto cada vez menos interesante
a medida que se perfecciona si
simplemente se puede describir una
canción de obtenerla al instante por
supuesto
eso nos va a dejar sin trabajo pero
sobre todo es aburrido
[Música]
ese álbum Lo creamos de manera rígida
con unas reglas estrictas Ahora lo único
que queremos es divertirnos Lo
terminamos Y de alguna manera entramos
en un periodo posting Inteligencia
artificial y solo queremos hacer música
que se sienta bien que sea muy humana y
que dé ganas de bailar para sus próximos
lanzamientos la banda privilegiará Los
instrumentos tradicionales Pero ha
prometido seguir de cerca en el futuro
la colaboración entre la sensibilidad
humana y la Inteligencia artificial
[Música]